l'énigme est un concours qui est ouvert
à tous
et c'était un concours numérique dont
comme en fait et les énigmes sont à sont
à résoudre exclusivement en ligne sur le
site internet des archives et donc il
s'agit d'un parcours avec une série de
deux petites enquêtes une série de
petites questions qu'il va falloir
résoudre en allant chercher et en
consultant des documents d'archivés dans
ce concours en fait il y a deux
catégories vous avez une catégorie quand
son public qui est couverte donc
vraiment à tout voir résidente en france
et une catégorie spécifique pour les
collégiens des yvelines
[Musique]
cette année on s'est focalisé vraiment
sûr sur le moyen-âge et cette fameuse
dame au fond on monte il va falloir
retrouver l'identité on va sur la trace
de personnages qui ont réellement existé
et donc pour justement à l'histoire et
la mémoire dans les documents d'archivés
[Musique]
le concours pas récompensé
trente joueurs grand public et 30 soir
collégiens on va pouvoir gagner des
tablettes des ordinateurs des drones
[Musique]